-We're getting you at a very
good time in your career.
-We have you here
as a TV star and movie star.
You did --
You were like a lot of us.
You were a stand-up
in the early days.
-I prefer movie star
and TV star now.
-Understood.
-But that's fine, that's fine.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. I'll invert.
I mean, I was building
to the bigger one.
You like to back --
-TV will be there for me
to fall back on, but let's hop
that doesn't happen.
[ Laughter ]
-What were your early days
of stand-up --
-I want to play panicky,
animated animals
for the rest of my life.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you very excited --
Now that you're kind of
looking through the Disney
catalog, seeing what's nex
for the next --
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
"What are you gonna remake now
and is there a kind of irritable
animal that can tell peopl
where things are because that,
if I'm gonna be typecast,
that's me.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. I did stand-up
before I came here.
-And how did it go?
-I mean, not amazing.
The thing with stand-up
in Britain is,
there's a period of time -
I mean, it's the same here
like, physically --
There's a period of time
before you get to the stag
where the audience can see you
but you don't have the ability
to start speaking yet.
And in Britain,
they're kind of just sizing up
your physical weaknesses..
[ Laughter ]
...to then use against you
So I had round glasses
at the time,
and it was the time that
Harry Potter was a big deal.
So, yeah, I wouldn't be able
to get to say my first jok
before people go,
"All right, Potter!"
[ Laughter ]
"All right, Potter,
where is Ron?
Where's Ron?"
[ Laughter ]
And, you know,
I'd, "Oh, okay."
They go, "No, seriously,
where is he?
Where is he, Harry?"
And so it was kind of the thin
that I had to --
the challenge
I had to overcome a lot.
And then I got
the job here thinking,
"Oh, this is gonna be great.
I was working for Jon Stewar
at "The Daily Show."
So my very first day
on "The Daily Show," I was -
I'd flown in the previous night.
I was exhausted.
I did my bit with Jon.
Panicky.
My legs were shaking.
I turned around
and sitting in the front row
around where you are
was J.K. Rowling.
[ Laughter ]
J.K. Rowling.
And she came 'round afterwards
And I was kind of
babbling at her, saying,
"It's my first day in America.
[ Laughter ]
"Is it normal
that you're here every night?"
[ Laughter ]
And she hugged me,
and it was amazing.
She was kind of saying,
"Oh, it's okay. It's --"
[ Laughter ]
And there was nothing
I wanted more in that moment
than a hug from J.K. Rowling
[ Laughter ]
And then she leaned back,
and she held me by the shoulders
and she said,
"You look so much like Harry."
[ Laughter ]
And that was not true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Only if -- Only if Harry had
been held back a few years
If Hogwarts had not gone
as well for him academically
as he wanted it.
-And then she -- Is this true?
She also very seriously
asked you, "Where's Ron?"
[ Laughter ]
-"Seriously, where is he?"
-"If I don't know --"
-Exactly.
-Yeah. It's trouble.
-Yeah.
-The last time you were here
it was February,
and we were talking, and you
were saying it's way too early
to talk about
the Democratic primaries.
-Yeah.
-And we're going live
for the debates...
-Yeah, have fun with that.
-...on Tuesday and Wednesday
-That's fun.
-Do you think
that's a good idea?
-No.
You mean, for you, physically?
-Yeah, for us to go live.
-No, it's a terrible idea.
I mean, I guess
there'll be things to say.
You'll find things to say.
-We'll find things to say.
-But I certainly don't env
the rapid turnaround.
-Yeah, it's a very fast
turnaround.
Do you -- Have you found -
Did you get anything of sort o
nutritional value out of the
first two nights of debates?
-Not really.
-Yeah, not really.
-It feels like it --
It's all warming up, isn't it?
-Yeah.
-It feels like they're all -
It feels like a shootaroun
in a basketball game right now
-Yeah.
I feel like it's like --
I said this before,
but it's like the beginnin
of a "Real Housewives"
where it's just them turning
and saying, like --
[ Laughter ]
Saying, like, "I'm here to
school you on education."
It's like, "All right."
-That is true.
And in about a few debates
time, it's, like, gonna be
an episode of "Housewives" where
they go on holiday together,
and you're like,
"Oh [bleep]
I see a bowl of margarita mix.
This is about to go down."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Well, it will be worth it
to go live after that one.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Hey, thanks for being here.
It's always such a pleasur
to see you.
John Oliver, everybody.